how to market a photography business I
got a great question for one of my
readers love you guys
Carice who wrote in to say I'm a
photographer I don't know how to get
started and how to bring my product the
people and show its value especially in
the market where everyone thinks they're
a photographer this is a great question
and one that I feel for you because
photography is such a difficult business
there's so many people who say they're a
photographer and you're not up against
only other photographers but also people
say oh you know my cousin Jill can do
that or my nephew can take care of that
there's not a lot of respect by a lot of
people for photography so how do you
demonstrate your value and market
yourself I love an example that I'm
going to share of a friend of mine his
name was rich he runs a company called
you gotta love he's a highly successful
photographer and I wanted to share some
lessons from him tell his story that
will hopefully help you market and grow
your photography business as well so the
first part is stand for something you
have to stand for something that the
problem with photography businesses are
that it's so hard to tell what's
different from you versus everybody else
everybody looks the same so if I'm
looking at you versus ten other
photographers why should I pick you over
everybody else what's the reason
and why should I pay you more if you're
charging two thousand dollars five
thousand dollars whatever is why should
I pay you that versus having somebody
who's coming in and say 150 bucks or my
nephew who do it for free how do you
show that guy so the first part is
standing for something okay so which
stands for inspire for him he likes
taking inspirational pictures he loves
making inspirational videos everything
is about inspire for him the pictures
that he wants to take the clients he
works best best with are the people who
want inspirational pictures pictures
that make them look good you look at the
picture and you feel inspired that's
what he wants to make so it helps people
not only identify which company to go
with which is hopefully you but also
tells them who not to go with so if you
want a boring corporate photo shoot
you're not going to
with rich it won't appeal to you you're
gonna look at this site and say wow this
is so not for me which is great you
don't want those people which doesn't
want those people but when somebody
wants an inspirational photo shoot and
then look at his website and they
compared to everybody else in Wow I want
that guy that's exactly what I want and
I'm willing to pay a premium for it so
you have to stand for something
important to help make you stand out
from everybody else because you're
boring so many photography businesses
are just boring you melt one into
another into another and it's impossible
to tell the difference between them okay
stand for something number two pick a
niche you want to find a niche that you
love working with again that will help
you stand out from everybody else who is
an ideal client for you
who do you love working with you have a
passion for and it's outside of
photography you love these kinds of
people so for rich he loves working with
celebrities he loves working with
celebrities he does really well with
them he makes him feel comfortable at
ease and they love working with him some
people hate working with celebrities
they say they're egotistical they're big
you know problem clients I hate working
with these guys but rich has a knack for
and he loves that's what he thrives on
he's shot you know Lady Gaga Kardinal
Offishall a whole bunch of musicians
he just loves working with celebrities
and that comes across in his work and he
ends up getting referrals and repeat
business because of it who do you love
working with pick a niche and be that
person so say you love I'll pick one for
me I love baseball say you love baseball
you could be the baseball photographer
any time a baseball player wanted a
photo shoot you're gonna be the person
to go do they look on your website and
they see you stand for something
important like inspire and you love
baseball players there's no choice right
that's why they're gonna pay you $5,000
for a photo shoot
instead of $500 for the next guy because
you are the guy who they love to work
with you love baseball and you stand for
something that they believe in as well
and you you're gonna have more fun
you're gonna have more fun doing it
because you're working with people who
you love to
with so pick a niche I can you have to
stand out from all the other photography
businesses that are out there third
strategy is partner up so rich again
he's trying to target celebrities
musicians he works to agencies so a lot
of agencies will recommend him because
they need new cover work for their CD
that they're launching or the new new
new you know face shots headshots for
their their upcoming acts and they know
that rich is the guy to go to so instead
of selling the customers one at a time
he works in partnership with agencies
who they can refer in businesses their
companies to work with their artists to
work with every week right keep just
funneling him new business so you want
to think about once you different you
wants you to find who your target
audience is right so if it's baseball
players or musicians or whoever it is
think about who is already selling to
them and how can you make an
introduction to them because the easiest
way to grow your business is to partner
up with somebody who already has your
target market and find a way to work
together okay if you do those three
things then you're standing for
something important you're finding a
niche that means something to you and
you're partnering up with people in that
industry you are on path to build a
highly successful photography business
that will now finally make you stand out
help demonstrate your value and help
make you start earning the money that
you deserve to make believe those are
you watching like the video thumbs up
below let me know what you think leave a
comment underneath
ask me a question my community response
and you want to see more videos like
this click on my face to subscribe to
the channel thank you so much I'll see
you soon
you